it was and I think reflecting on this
think they'll be thinking the decision
to invite him back at all as backfired
massively on sheffield united and
they've effectively acknowledged that by
this decision to step away from that
invitation to invite said evans to train
with him it did feel like unseemly haste
the speed with which ched Evans was
reintegrated to Sheffield United even
though as they're saying here this was
never a firm contract offer they seem to
be falling over themselves almost to get
him back in the fold them and they paid
and three million pounds for this player
before he was jailed for rape and one
always did have the sense that there
might be an attempted to try and recoup
some of that investment they would say
they were also trying to look after
contribute perhaps of the rehabilitation
of a man who as many have said it served
his time but with the the weight of
public opinion and really senior people
big public profile like Jess ennis-hill
who wanted her name removed from the
stand and a host of others the weight of
public opinion made this a very
difficult decision to go through with I
think there'll be many particularly
those who said this is not an issue
about football this is an issue about
the victims of rape this is a man who's
unapologetic unrepentant and football
must take us down they will welcome this
step from sheffield united public
opinion public pressure from figures
like Jess ennis-hill but also from
sponsors as well pulled it's indeed they
had two of their sponsors front and back
of the shirt who were threatening to
walk away if they went through with this
decision to re-sign him and you know
there'll be those who say this is a
financial decision that ultimately money
has talked in this case it's an
interesting example that commercial
sponsors caps can bring their weight to
bear of course all of this generally
generated by media heat in the first
place in the case of ched evans the
media heat came from a very effective
petition campaign that was put together
calling for evans not to be called back
for this fundamental issue that he was a
man who you know rape is not like any
other crime at ease at the very end of
the most serious crimes that people can
commit and for a football club to walk
back in this way so apparently so
quickly and heedless of those cans
they say in the statement they're not
heedless of them but it was it just
seemed a very very quick process and
this is a this is a shed Evans we will
see what happens to him in his career
but wherever he goes to play I think
this is a lesson about the publicity
that will follow him wherever he goes